rebuild britain after coronavirus but
with dramatic changes that's the call
from 300 leading business charity and
religious leaders they want an overhaul
of the economy an end to inequality and
a 30 billion pound focus on
environmental policies like retrofitting
homes across the country to make them
energy-efficient something architect
Robert Pruitt spent thousands of his own
pounds doing almost a quarter of our co2
emissions result from just us being in
homes deep retrofit to hundreds of
thousands millions of homes would start
to reduce that dramatically down to only
a few percent of our co2 emissions the
call comes as a survey found that only
6% of people want things to return to
the way they were before coronavirus
with no changes 81% want government
created jobs for those who lost theirs
during the crisis and more than half say
tackling climate change now needs to be
a priority what's really interesting is
that this isn't about left or right and
actually organizations from across the
political spectrum with diverse views
have all come together and they are
saying we must build back better there
is a new common sense emerging there is
a new consensus emerging and actually
the public are with us 60% of the public
want to see changes in how they economy
is run there is significant support for
a so-called green recovery the chairs of
to House of Commons committees have
written to the Chancellor warning time
is running out to avert an even greater
future global crisis caused by climate
change other policies being discussed by
the 300 include a national care service
and minimum income protection the prime
minister has promised to spend big to
help Britain recover but he'll need a
hundred billion and a radical change of
policy to achieve these demands Sam
Holder Sky News